[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie awesome news
recently Kevin Feige was doing press for
the Captain Marvel movie people were
asking him about Marvel phase 4 because
we have all this x-men and Fantastic
Four stuff that are coming into the
universe we already have an idea where
the next two to three years are for sure
and then he says that they have
officially planned up to the next six
years so I'll break it all down there's
a new round of that imax ticket giveaway
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about
phase 4 on the video so I'll do this top
10 style starting with number 10 Kevin
Feige said that they were waiting till
after Avengers endgame to do their next
big phase reveal panel remember a couple
years ago when Kevin Feige and Marvel
did this special phase 3 panel at the El
Capitan where they brought a couple
journalists and did their own version of
Hall H panel and announced everything
that was happening between 2016 and 2019
movies they were doing that's when they
announced Benedict Cumberbatch was going
to be their version of Doctor Strange it
was wonderful he did not say whether or
not they're gonna do that this time or
they're just gonna wait till their
comic-con panel after Dark Phoenix comes
out because x-men will be a big part of
what happens during phase 4 and phase 5
number 9 though all those plans that he
talks about the next six years include
more than just the movies even though
that's what we're mostly focused on they
also include all the core Marvel
Cinematic Universe Avengers TV series
for the Disney Plus streaming service
the Loki show Scarlet Witch envision the
Winter Soldier Falcon team-up show and
we've already found out that they're
going to be developing x-men based TV
shows which is no surprise there's a
billion characters even if they do three
movies per year for the next six years
that's only 18 movies there's no way
they're gonna get to everything with all
the sequels that they already have
planned because we do have a pretty good
idea for what the schedule is gonna look
like so the logical next step is is just
to do a really awesome miniseries for
your really big characters that you just
don't have time for in the movies the
really cool thing about the TV series
too is that they also help fill gaps in
programming especially if they have to
swerve on a movie like guardians of the
galaxy 3 it was gonna be released next
summer
now Marvel because they took it off
their schedule has no movie coming out
next summer and there's only two movies
whereas Kevin Feige is like we're
definitely doing three movies per year
so there's this giant gap but they have
all these new special Marvel Studios
limited series they're making with the
movie actors that'll help fill that gap
so it's not as big a deal as it would
have been before but number 8 the
roadmap that Kevin Feige said that he
has is demarcated by the next Avengers
movies no surprise there the Avengers
movies are sort of like your big
signposts in the roadmap that is the MCU
every year you do the cooler smaller
solo movies but then every couple of
years you have your big universe
shattering Avengers movies where the
status quo the MCU is shaken going
forward but here's the thing because
they just did Avengers movies back to
back we might not get that next Avengers
movie Avengers 5 for three more years if
they don't want to do it every other
year then you had Captain America Civil
War which fell in between age of Ultron
and infinity war in that was sort of
Avengers 2.5 so even if they start
spacing out they're really big Avengers
movies more they'll still be Avengers
crossovers every other year so there's
still be a lot of really really big
stuff going on outside of the little
solo movies seven officially right now
spider-man far from home is the first
Marvel phase for movies so it's like the
first movie set in the new status quo
the MCU post Avengers endgame remember
we're expecting a lot of big changes
there's still a lot of theories about
that so it's still wide open to
speculation the biggest of those changes
just incorporating characters that have
biologically-based powers a la x-men the
spider-man movies are a perfect example
of this difference so before he came
into the MCU spider-man villains the
characters were largely biology based
there are a couple of technology-based
characters but the big difference when
they brought him into the MCU is that
because so much of their movie universe
is driven by the vision of that first
Iron Man film you started to see more
spider-man villains that are cut from
that same cloth the look in the visual
design is much more inspired by the Iron
Man movies so just picture mutants in
the MCU that's probably the easiest way
to think about it but number six we
already know what a good number of the
other movies are going to be the next
two to three years for sure because of
the announcements that they've already
made the last year but the early
versions of the lists here and the
schedules don't include MCU Fantastic
Four or x-men films because Marvel
technically isn't allowed to start
planning yet Bob Iger even said that
their lawyer at Disney won't let him
talk about doing x-men films until the
ink is dry which right now is gonna be
earlier this summer so even though Kevin
Feige can come up with ideas he's not
allowed to talk to anyone about them yet
but number five Black Widow which we
know about will not be rated our Kevin
Feige confirmed that they never planned
on making it r-rated there are a lot of
news articles people like will this be
the first hard-core MCU film the problem
being I think that there are a lot of
younger kids that like the Black Widow
character you make it rated R you
automatically cut Disney off from that
large family audience and during a
recent earnings call Bob Iger also
addressed this issue where he's like you
know it's not a Disney's nature to
release r-rated films that's what Fox is
gonna be for so they're still gonna keep
a certain portion of Fox intact for
releasing those hardcore movies
particularly the Deadpool movies because
while Kevin Feige will be officially
managing all the characters like he'll
be the one to greenlight new Marvel
movies when they have a rated R film
like Deadpool three Disney themselves
will not slap their name on it number
four you guys will be really happy about
this he did confirm that Nova was really
high on their list of other cosmic
characters that are gonna get their own
solo films I know we're all wondering
about Silver Surfer but they own Nova no
problem they could do a Nova movie
tomorrow if they wanted to but number
three he also doubled down on Kamala
Khan miss Marvel they said it's high on
their list and the current plan is to
debut her during Captain Marvel 2 which
they did confirm at the press conference
will be set in present-day
because this is the whole reason for not
including Kamala Khan miss Marvel in the
first Captain Marvel movie is because
that's a period piece set during the 90s
in their version of Kamala Khan felt
like a contemporary story said in
present day so in talking about their
desire to do Kamala Khan in the sequel
they sort of confirmed a couple of
things like yep definitely gonna be said
in present day during the sequel we're
definitely planning on there being a
sequel and we're gonna debut Miss Marvel
during that so if you're a big fan of
that character or you just want to see a
version of Miss Marvel on screen it
sounds like it's gonna happen in the
next two to three years but number two
here is the official tentative schedule
for the next three years or so so this
is actually pretty set unless there's
some giant catastrophe in that to
shuffle some movies around so next year
is going to be Black Widow in the
Eternals movie in that order
then during 2021 it's black panther 2 in
February they'll probably do another
black history month release Doctor
Strange too
and spider-man 3 whatever that's going
to be called spider-man coming home
something riffing on the title home
because spider-man homecoming spider-man
far from home so whatever your theories
are about spider-man just make sure you
include home in the title of that third
film and then maybe if they want to do
Avengers films every two years you also
have Avengers 5 that year because
technically Kevin Feige said that
they're doing three movies a year but
spider-man 3 is a Sony film Sony
releases those so technically it's not
on that three movies a year Disney lists
that he's talking about but then the
year after that it would be guardians of
the galaxy 3 they're still planning on
using James Gunn's script so they'll
probably be a little while before they
announced what they're gonna do with
that and when they're gonna start
production then Captain Marvel 2 just
assuming that there's gonna be a sequel
maybe a Fantastic Four film I have a
feeling that they'll probably be one of
the first films that they do when they
get those characters but remember this
is 2022 so it's a couple years away
meaning that they wouldn't even start
developing it till later this year so
beyond that there's a lot of speculation
like Nova eternals to remember there's
gonna be sequels to a lot of the new
movies that they debut at some point
they're gonna do another ant-man and the
wasp film set in the quantum realm then
you have all the potential x-men films
that they'll do those all have to fit
somewhere in the schedule you have the
Deadpool sequels that'll be in there so
just remember they Kevin Feige said
three movies per year but there might be
a little wiggle room on that where they
use Fox to release some of those so
between the two studios it might wind up
being like four films per year but the
biggest thing on everyone's mind
number one Kevin Feige revealed last
year that it would still be a good long
while before we see x-men vs. Avengers
teaming up in a really really big
Avengers film that means it probably
won't be Avengers 5
there'll be x-men characters showing up
in and around Marvel movies in the MCU
so the x-men films separately from that
and it won't take quite as long as it
took them to get that first Avengers
movie together took four years between
the first Iron Man in the Avengers
before they all came together so that's
why tentatively I would assume that
Avengers 6 will be like the first really
big film where you see a ton of Avengers
in a ton of x-men together on screen but
like I said avengers endgame comes out
at the end of April then you have
spider-man far from home at the
beginning of July the x-men Disney deal
will be done by then because far from
home is dropping so close to comic-con
pretty likely that they'll just wait to
their Hall H panel before
us a big schedule and then saying this
is what we're doing with all those x-men
characters and Fantastic Four post all
your Marvel phase four x-men theories in
the comments below what will happen is
is there supposed to be a new Dark
Phoenix trailer really soon there's
supposed to be new Shazam Game of
Thrones Season eight trailer when that
stuff drops I will totally make videos
for it no worries while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new
spider-man far from home trailer video
and click here to learn all about
Godspeed coming to the flash during
season 5 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
[Music]